You can just follow your "List" or check out
the "what's new" or "what's hot" tabs, or
you can dig a little deeper into the Netflix
archives to find some truly outstanding, under-the-radar
films.
Here's a look at some of the best stuff to
add to your queue the next time you don't
know what to watch.
The Duffer Brothers might allude to their
Spielbergian influences and aims in Stranger
Things, but Rim of the World director McG
unabashedly and cheerfully made an '80s-style
kid adventure movie.
Rim of the World mixes elements of E.T., The
Goonies, and Red Dawn to create a similarly
fun sci-fi action movie where teens save the
day.
"If you find yourself alone, riding in green
fields with the sun on your face, do not be
troubled.
For you are in Elysium.
And you are already dead."
The simple, irresistible premise: four kids
arrive at summer camp just in time for an
invasion of the planet by wicked aliens.
With the well-populated "Rim of the World"
camp soon abandoned, it's up to this ragtag
group of teens who don't quite fit in elsewhere
to come together and thwart what amounts to
the end of the world.
They'll have to do it all without adults,
computers, or much of anything… except,
of course, for bikes.
Heaven of Horror says of this lightweight
diversion:
"This is an absolute treat for fans of sci-fi,
adventure, action, and monster movies."
After bringing so much attention and accolades
to Netflix via his unforgettable performance
as Sheriff Hopper on Stranger Things, it's
no surprise that David Harbour has free reign
to do whatever he wants at the streaming giant.
And what he wants to do is a meta, sci-fi
and horror-laced mockumentary about his life,
a collaboration with Arrested Development
writer John Levenstein.
The result is a short special that's a bit
hard to define.
Frankenstein's Monster's Monster, Frankenstein
is based around a mid-1970s made-for-TV production
of the two-man theatrical version of Frankenstein.
The twist is that Harbour plays his own "father,"
also an actor named David Harbour, as the
two generations play both Dr. Frankenstein
and his monstrous creation at the same time.
To round out this tribute from the younger
Harbour to the fictional older Harbour are
clips of the actor from other vintage fictional
productions like The Crying Detective and
The Actor's Trunk.
The whole thing winds up both a love letter
to the craft of acting and an affectionate
send-up of the entire notion of playing pretend
for a living.
This 2017 indie horror movie by writer/director
Trey Edward Shults feels like an old-fashioned
kind of horror movie.
Sure, it trades in spooky monsters and frightening
imagery, but it's more about conjuring up
what's already inside the viewer: the unspeakable
dread of things yet to come.
It Comes at Night is set deep in a remote
woodland area not long after an epidemic has
wiped out most human life on earth.
It's where the small family of Paul, Sarah,
and young Travis try to survive on what little
supplies they've got and hope they don't get
infected with the plague.
But then danger comes looking for them in
the form of a roving family man named Will,
who is maybe not the innocent guy he claims
to be.
"Hey, listen.
I don't even have to shoot you, you know?
I could just leave you out here.
You want this water?"
"Yeah."
"Make me believe you."
Still, Sarah invites Will and his family into
their homestead on the theory of strength
in numbers, but that only seems to invite
more danger...
most of it impossibly horrific, lurking out
there in the forest.
The London Evening Standard's Charlotte O'Sullivan
said of the film:
"It made me so tense I could hardly breathe,
let alone think."
Vietnam is home to a quickly developing movie
culture and industry, and the action thriller
Furie teams up two of its stars, director
Le-Van Kiet and actress Veronica Ngo , best
known to Western audiences as gunner Paige
Tico in Star Wars: The Last Jedi.
In Furie, Ngo portrays a former criminal overlord
who now works as the muscle for a loan shark
in the city of Can Tho, shaking down delinquents
with a shattering of a kneecap or two.
That violence comes home to roost when her
daughter, Mai, is kidnapped and seemingly
sold to black market organ dealers.
Ngo, propelled by equal parts rage, guilt,
and love, takes to the seedy sides of Ho Chi
Minh City to get her daughter back in one
piece.
Furie is a tight, often sparse ride, which
includes plenty of novel set pieces, beautiful
cinematography, and an intense motorbike chase.
Sometimes the scariest parts of a scary movie
don't come from monsters or gore, but from
menace and dread.
That's what propels the precisely paced Earthquake
Bird, based on the novel of the same name
by Susanna Jones.
Alicia Vikander of Ex Machina returns to the
kind of moody, unsettling cinema that made
her famous, portraying Lucy, a Swedish expatriate
who has settled into a life in 1989 Tokyo
that is repetitive, bland, and mundane.
It's by design, as she's looking to flee from
and forget past traumas.
She works as a translator, living alone while
maintaining some low-key friendships and playing
cello in a string quartet.
One day, Lucy meets Teiji, a noodle shop worker
and aspiring photographer.
She enchants him and lets him make portraits
of her.
"I've never had my picture taken before.
Not properly."
"Then, I'm the first."
But just when it seems like her icy veneer
is starting to thaw, Lucy's life is interrupted
by a brash American named Lily, who goes missing
and is presumed dead.
Is the mysterious Lucy responsible, either
via conscious act or her status as a tragedy
magnet?
Or is she merely an unreliable narrator?
Gabriel Silver of the Detroit Metro Times
said:
"Earthquake Bird is an enjoyable neo-noir
film, with enough twists and turns to leave
you thinking long after the ending."
Yes, it's a thriller set at a lake deep in
the woods, and a young person dies very early
on in the movie.
Apart from that setup and the notion that
an unrepentant killer could strike at any
time Every Time I Die is as far away as can
be from your typical horror.
The film follows the forlorn Sam, who is still
recovering from the childhood tragedy of losing
a sister to drowning.
Now a paramedic, he keeps his mind off of
his troubles with an ongoing affair with a
married woman that is, until he's killed at
the hands of her husband, returning soldier
Tyler.
That's when Every Time I Die takes a turn.
Drew's unsettled consciousness floats into
the bodies of his friends, attempting to warn
them that they could be the next to die.
The film's tightly-packed 98 minute running
time and minuscule budget serve it well, as
it winds up a rarity in cinema: a pensive
thriller.
Andrew Stover of Film Inquiry said of Every
Time I Die:
"It's a captivating little tale about self-image,
with a mystical and poignant touch."
Don is just a regular guy, a lawyer whose
life has taken a few bad turns because of
his own bad decisions.
Seeking a fresh start before his wife Liz
gives birth to their first child, he buys
a decrepit old house way out in suburban Chicago.
He moves in first, so that he can pour himself
into renovating this old, spooky manor.
Somehow, Don doesn't go screaming back into
the city when he discovers that the house
bleeds and excretes a strange white fluid
out of its pipes, or when he keeps discovering
human and animal corpses and freaky, ghostly
monsters.
As if all that isn't enough, he's got to contend
with a flirty neighbor who may know more about
the source of the house's horrors than she's
letting on.
Girl on the Third Floor marks the screenwriting
and directorial debut of veteran horror producer
Travis Stevens.
The haunted house movie is a well-traveled
genre, but Stevens tweaks the formula enough
to leave audiences guessing, entertained,
and unsettled.
Based on the originality and success of The
Matrix, Hollywood has frequently given the
Wachowskis a blank check to make whatever
visually dazzling, unabashedly earnest, and
totally bonkers sci-fi movie they felt like
making.
One of those movies is Jupiter Ascending,
which stars Mila Kunis as Jupiter Jones, a
Russian-American house cleaner and amateur
astronomer.
Through a string of events that involves selling
her eggs to pay for a telescope, she finds
out she's some kind of space princess.
The Abrasax clan, a prominent galactic family,
wants her dead, or maybe just control of her
birthright.
Fortunately, she's got the steadfast protection
from Caine Wise, played by Channing Tatum,
a half-human/half-wolf super-soldier.
Jupiter Ascending is a bit of an overstuffed
sci-fi extravaganza, and it has everything,
from jet packs to giant spaceships to hand-to-hand
combat to Sean Bean playing a rogue bee-man.
Stephanie Cooke of Rogues Portal manages to
sum up the film's many joys in one pithy remark:
"Ever wondered what Cinderella, The Godfather,
and Teen Wolf would be like if they were one
movie?"
"No?
Well, too bad because Jupiter Ascending exists."
"Not a pretty sight… snipped and stripped,
the mark of a court martial skyjacking.”
You still haven’t answered my question do
you want your wings back or not?
“Wait, you had wings?"
Why are period horror films so much scarier
than ones set in the modern day?
Is it because the relative ignorance and brutality
of the past adds an extra element of terror?
Or are images of Victorian-era Londoners in
bleak clothes living bleak lives inherently
unsettling?
That could be the answer, although blood-hungry
monsters, freaky islands, and blood cults
are scary too.
Fortunately, Apostle showcases all that and
much more.
Set in 1905, Apostle follows a man named Thomas,
who leaves London for an island paradise off
the coast of Wales.
It's run by a cult, and Thomas must retrieve
his sister, taken to the island by the group
and held for ransom.
He poses as a new adherent to gain favor with
the cult members and their leader, Prophet
Malcolm, all while aiming to get his sister
back.
However, things get awfully sticky for Thomas
when he realizes that the cult's teachings
aren't exactly crazy.
Those jars of blood everyone carries around
to collect their blood sacrifice to the island?
The island needs that blood.
Imagine if Little Shop of Horrors mashed up
with The Wicker Man and you've got Apostle.
"She gifted me her wisdom.
She trusted me that I may enrich your minds."
According to the thoughtful sci-fi movie Io,
humanity is doomed to never change its ways,
and in the not-too-distant future, Earth becomes
uninhabitable.
Fortunately, scientists have found a new home
for mankind on Io, one of Jupiter's many moons.
A scientist named Sam is among the handful
of humans who haven't made the migration to
Io just yet, staying behind to test the water
and air for signs of decreasing toxicity,
as well as to raise bees that she hopes could
someday pollinate and help save the planet's
vegetation.
Time is running out, and certain catastrophic
events lead Sam to head with another survivor,
Micah, to a shuttle that will take them into
space.
Io is full of philosophical and mental tension
as these two bear witness to what could be
Earth's final, extinctive whimper, but also
a newfound hope for the future.
Leigh Monson of Birth.Movies.Death. says:
"If you're looking for science fiction that
makes manifest the anxieties of a dying world,
our dying world, then Io is a good place to
start."
"We weren't ready for this.
No matter what warning we got from your father."
What if John Wick were more like an '80s movie?
More violent, more nihilistic, more violence-soaked
and with more absolutely unnecessary nudity,
all with a gleeful undercurrent of shock humor
permeating the whole thing?
That's Polar, the bonkers, messy story of
one man's quest to relax and secure his pension.
Mads Mikkelsen, the Danish actor best known
for his starring role on the stylish TV version
of Hannibal, stars as Duncan Vizla, a.k.a.
the Black Kaiser.
Duncan is a highly effective assassin forced
by his oddly corporate bosses to retire at
age 50 and enjoy his golden years.
Of course, his company plans to kill him off
to avoid paying his payout.
From a lovely cabin in Montana, Duncan has
to fight off some violent attacks while also
dealing with PTSD and forging a friendship
with a neighbor with demons of her own.
"I know they pay you well for this Vivian.
I’m still going to give you a chance to
walk out of here alive.
For old time's sake."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.